cela donne chaque année des touristes
par milliers de tout genre de tout
milieu un brassage d'idées un mixage
d'anorac bref de quoi recevoir une
petite carte postale couleur couchée de
soleil sur le Montblanc qui fait tout de
même bien plaisir des vacances vous en
voulez en voilà la montagne se prête à
tous les capric son air vivifiant vous
donnera l'air que vous aimez avoir plein
de santé et plein de vie à la ville au
champ en famille en société l'alpinisme
on ne fait pas sans essayer au moins une
petite grimpette un peu de sport mon
cher vous vous empâtez Monsieur Météo
est en vacances lui aussi ennuyeux ça il
va falloir faire un effort se renseigner
soi-même qu'àa ne tienne je ferai de
l'alpinisme si le temps est beau et même
si cela me fatigue j'ai toute l'année
pour me reposer au bureau lieu commun
toujours en usage et toujours apprécié